And the answer is the first message is the only
valid message. The message is no good because
it’s encrypted using the public key of node 5 and
so node 1 won't be able to decrypt it. The rest of
this, all use the public key of node 1. The third
option won't work because there is only one hub.
And because there is only one hub, node 1 can
see that the message came from Alice and is
going to Bob and this is what we don’t want to
know it to be able to learn.
The second option won't work because after node
1, message is directed to go to node 3 which is
encrypted using a public key of node 4. And so
node 3 won't be able to decrypt the rest of this
message. The first option works, it’s encrypted
using the public key of node 1, so node 1 can
decrypt it. It’s directed to send it to node 2 and it’s
encrypted using the public key of node 2 and so
that hub work. Node 2 is then directed to send the
message to Bob which is encrypted with the public
key of Bob, so Bob will be able to decrypt the
message and receive Onions Galore.